there was a lot of men on this side it
was a romantic thing all around there
was a baker's dozen on this the two of
you though
like is there special things we often
say tables you know shared a horse with
somebody yeah most of us when I hit the
gym together and stuff and that's that's
like footballing that's there's that
goes out the window trust me
the horsemanship I was talking to Chris
and he said that you guys don't look
really all that good out of him
there was Austin I bear was the only
person who was like proficiently showing
off I was like cool man
like we're struggling so your wife who
plays your wife in the film said that
you guys would because you have a scene
when you're in bed together and this
film that you'd be in bed together you'd
be like let's practice like that's
process yeah I remember we were seeing
pictures and I was like wow I haven't
had a hot wife in this movie there's a
oh there's my wife I swear you didn't
know I didn't know I didn't know that
was where everything oh yeah I'm like
dude shut up
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]